a pris la fuite les autorités sont à sa
recherche actuellement ils pourraient
avoir pris un train notamment pour
partir en direction de l'état du
maryland
tout cela reste évidemment à confirmer
l'enquêté suit son cours les certaines
stations de métro sont fermées dans la
ville de washington justement parce que
les autorités sont toujours à la
recherche du suspect qui est donc
ensuite en tout cas suite à ces coups de
feu outre le fait que le pentagone ait
été bouclée il ya évidemment eu un
dispositif de sécurité très important
qui a été déployée avec des forces de
police mais aussi des premiers secours
qui sont intervenus sur les lieux du
drame où on a pu voir sur certaines
images
justement les gestes de premiers secours
effectué sur un certain nombre de
victimes qui ont ensuite été transportés
à l'hôpital le métro et les bus ne
marquent plus l'arrêt à la station de
bus en question ou évidemment la
fusillade s'est déroulée ce matin
alors cette sous station de bus et une
centre de transit et un centre de
transit où circulent chaque jour des
milliers de personnes notamment des
employés du pentagone le pentagone qui
on le rappelle est un bâtiment hautement
sécurisé et parfois même présenté comme
l un des bâtiments les plus sécurisés du
monde
il faut dire enfin que le nombre de
fusillades est en hausse ces derniers
mois aux états unis mais évidemment ces
faits ne se produisent que très rarement
à proximité très immédiate d'un bâtiment
officiel comme cela était le cas ce
matin près du pentagone
merci beaucoup aux abonnés pour toutes
ces précisions direct de washington
la quatrième vague poursuit sa
progression en france la corse déclenché
un plan blanc pour lutter contre la
recrudescence des cas de covile dans son
dernier rapport la rs de corse fait état
de 21 une nouvelle hospitalisation
seulement trois jours
mais c'est le département de la haute
corse qui semble le plus touché avec 10
personnes en réanimation et soins
intensifs contre 4,1 pour la corse du
sud
le centre hospitalier de bastia commence
déjà à être saturé le plan blanc qui je
le rappelle elle permet de notamment de
rappeler des soignants en congé de
déprogrammer des opérations et d'ouvrir
des filières supplémenté 1re confinement
inévitable pour la guadeloupe après une
flambée de contamination dès demain à
lille sera mise sous cloche situation
catastrophique à en croire les mots de
l' agence régionale de santé est tous
les indicateurs sont au rouge
les autorités locales n'ont d'autre
choix que de re confiné pour trois
semaines au but à des chiffres jamais
atteints depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
en plus de nouveaux cas la guadeloupe
est un département avec le plus haut à
niveau d'hospitalisation un couvre-feu
est instauré de 20h à 5h du matin et les
déplacements seront limités à 10
kilomètres autour du domicile sauf motif
impérieux avec attestation
la dégradation marquée de la situation
sanitaire sur la semaine passée et le
péril qui plane sur les capacités
hospitalières du territoire nécessite
d'ores et déjà de compléter le
couvre-feu en vigueur depuis vendredi
dernier dans cette perspective après
consultation des élus et des
représentants du milieu socio-économique
le préfet a décidé la mise en place d'un
confinement réévaluent à blanc
guadeloupe pour les trois prochaines
semaines
le respect strict des gestes barrières
des distanciation physique et du port du
masque à l'intérieur des établissements
recevant du public comme en extérieur
sur la voie publique doivent redevenir
la norme et constitue la principale
mesure contre cette quatrième vague qui
se présente déjà comme le plus grave
phénomène épidémique liés aux kovy 19
connu par la guadeloupe depuis mars 2020
pour daniel allain président du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
ces nouvelles mesures sont logiques
il rappelle le contexte est particulier
de l'île faut savoir que l'hôpital de la
guadeloupe a subi le chu tokoin de l'eau
a subi un incendie il ya quelques années
de ça il est le système de
l'hospitalisation est en pleine
réflexion
n'oublions pas que nous sommes sur des
îles
ils écoutent où les capacités sanitaires
sont naturellement faible par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans l'hexagone et je
pense que c'est par souci de prévention
qu'on a préféré mettre la guadeloupe
sous cloche au moin la fé pour la
martinique est elle aussi à la réunion
pour éviter que le qui est plus de jeux
d'essai n'oublions pas que 17 concerts
environ à peu près de 17% environ
guadeloupe et martinique est seulement
ils sont sont vaccinés est la france
n'est pas la seule à faire face à ces
variants delta flambé de contamination
au maroc qui tentent d'accélérer sa
campagne de vaccination les autorités
ont pris de nouvelles mesures
restrictives s'appliquant sur l'ensemble
du territoire
certaines villes ont même été placés en
confinement total les précisions de
notre correspondant au maghreb
bassam chebbi nouveau pic de
contamination coronavirus dans le
royaume du maroc un épisode épidémique
aussi importants que lors de la première
vague en novembre 2020 le pays
enregistre actuellement 5000 nouveaux
cas quotidiens
pour y faire face le gouvernement a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures et les
ville touristique d'agadir casablanca ou
encore marrakech sont confinés tandis
que le couvre-feu passe de 23h à 5h du
matin sur l'ensemble du territoire
marocain cafés et restaurants doivent
fermer leurs portes à 21h alors que les
rassemblements de plus de 25 personnes
sont interdits mariages fêtes événements
culturels sont pour le moment
interrompues et les lieux accueillant du
public voient leur capacité d'accueil
est réduite à 50% les déplacements entre
les différentes régions sont interdits
ainsi que l'accès aux villes confiné
sauf pour les marocains disposant d'un
passeport vaccinale les autorités
marocaines encouragent leurs populations
à privilégier le télétravail autres
mesures difficiles en pleine saison
estivale des hôtels et autres
établissements touristiques ne doivent
pas dépasser 75 % de leur capacité
d'accueil le royaume qui a pour ambition
de produire localement le vaccin chinois
de sinopharm poursuit sa campagne de
vaccination pour faire face au cours de
la vie russe à ce jour 24 millions de
doses du sérum astrazeneca et sinopharm
ont été administrées dans l'ensemble du
pays
en chine également l'inquiétude monte
suite à la confirmation de plusieurs
nouveaux cas du vin ayant delta haouran
berceau de l'épidémie et dans tout le
pays une situation plus qu'alarmante
alarmante
on fait le point avec far as milk
retour à la case départ un an après
avoir repris une vie presque normale
les habitants de bourg ain sont inquiets
trois nouveaux cas du variant delta ont
été confirmés lundi dans la capitale de
la province du hubei où le co vie de 19
a fait son apparition pour la première
fois fin 2019
les autorités locales s'activent pour
atteindre leurs objectifs
dépister les 11 millions d'habitants de
la ville le plus rapidement possible et
les enfants même en bas âge n'échappe
pas à la règle
nous avons décidé de procéder rapidement
à des tests d'acides nucléiques pour
tous les habitants de notre ville afin
de procéder à un dépistage complet des
cas positifs et d infection
asymptomatique
nous nous devons de prévenir de
contrôler précisément l'épidémie est de
bloquer efficacement les sources
possibles d'infection en mettant
l'accent sur la prévention strict des
cas importés afin de créer un
environnement de production et de vie
sur rassurant sans et ordonnée dans la
ville cette réapparition du virus à one
fait remonter de mauvais souvenirs à la
surface
la septième ville la plus peuplée du
pays a été la plus touchée par le cos
vite 19 en chine avec 3869 mort sur les
4636 annoncé par pékin où anne avait
alors été la première ville du monde
placé en quarantaine et la mégalopole
n'est pas la seule zone du territoire
touché par le variant delta près de 300
nouveaux cas ont été confirmés au total
depuis le mois de juillet par les
autorités dans plus d'une douzaine de
province à pékin 41 mille personnes ont
été dans l'obligation de se confiner
afin d'endiguer un foyer d'infection
un regain de contamination qui pousse le
gouvernement à prendre de nouvelles
mesures drastiques notamment dans la
capitale
jusqu'à présent pékin a pris plusieurs
mesures notamment la recherche des
contacts étroits et le bouclage des
zones concernées
l'enquêté épidémiologique pertinente le
séquençage du génome viral et le travail
de contrôle sont en cours selon le
jugement préliminaire neuf personnes ont
été en contact étroit avec le cas
confirmé susmentionnés et elles sont en
quarantaine d'autres contacts étroits
sont en cours de vérification
inquiète les autorités sanitaires
chinoises font leur possible pour
combler leur retard dans la vaccination
de la population selon la commission
nationale de la santé plus d'un milliard
de doses du vaccin local sinovac ont
déjà été administrées dans le pays
l'australie n'est pas non plus épargné
plusieurs villes dont sidney sont
confinés depuis quelques semaines les
militaires mois mettez à déployer pour
faire respecter ce confinement en
question afin de freiner l'épidémie le
gouvernement compte sur la vaccination
mais refuse d'organiser des opérations
pour inciter la population quant à mme
auclair
ça y est le bruit discussion houleuse au
sein du parlement australien
le premier ministre rejette
catégoriquement la proposition de
l'opposition d'indemniser les personnes
se faisant vacciner
la proposition du chef de l'opposition
anthony albanese et est un vote de
défiance est une insulte aux australiens
suggérant qu'ils ne se feront pas
vacciner
à moins que vont distribuer de l'argent
monsieur le président c'est une insulte
c'est une insulte à tous les australiens
aud 80% d'australiens âgées qui se sont
présentés et ont retroussé leurs manches
monsieur le président ils n'ont pas eu
besoin d'argent ils ont juste eu besoin
de savoir que c'était bon pour eux bon
pour leurs familles bon pour leur
communauté est bon pour leur pays
monsieur le président scott morrison
montre les dents face à l'opposition
pour autant l'immunité collective est
encore très loin d'être acquise en
australie seulement un peu plus de 19%
de la population sont entièrement
vacciner
la faute au lancement tardif de la
campagne de vaccination et aux nombreux
couacs liés au vaccin d'astrazeneca
conséquence le premier ministre se
retrouve très décriée mais les autorités
restent confiantes sur la volonté des
australiens de se faire vacciner
il y a des signes très forts qui montre
qu'une vaste majorité des australiens a
l'intention de se faire vacciner parce
que c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour le
moment vous savez nous ne pensons pas
que des incitations soit nécessaire et
comme je les dis c'est vraiment agréable
de voir combien l'australien sont prêts
à se faire vacciner si l'intention y est
les actes sont difficilement visibles et
le vaillant delta en profite pour se
propager dans le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines l'australie assez épargné
jusqu'à l'or connaît un regain
épidémique
plusieurs villes ont dû se recombiner à
sydney
le confinement est prévue au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de leur côté des
autorités régionales ont prolongé les
isolements obligatoire à brisbane
jusqu'à dimanche un minima nous espérons
éperdument que cela sera suffisant pour
que nos traceur de contacts permettent
de placer en quarantaine à domicile
absolument toute personne qui aurait pu
être exposés à la souche delta mais pour
que cela fonctionne pour que nous
puissions sortir de cette situation ce
week end nous avons besoin qu absolument
tout le monde reste à la maison si
possible dans ces endroits et frais
crème
les australiens contre un alignement ne
sont pas prêts de revoir des touristes
de sitôt l'australie n'a pas rouvert ses
frontières internationales depuis mars
2020 le premier ministre scott morrison
annoncé qu'une réouverture des
frontières serait envisagée seulement
quand 80% des australiens seront
entièrement vacciner un an jour pour
jour après l'explosion qui a ravagé le
port de beyrouth la france avec le
concours des nations unies organisent ce
mercredi une conférence internationale
sur le liban la troisième en un an
elle disait à collecter une aide
d'urgence d'au moins à 294 millions
d'euros pour le pays
le liban qui s'enfonce un peu plus dans
une crise économique dévastatrice celle
en quête de son côté qu etienne toujours
est el farj négligence criminelle
violation du droit à la vie et entrave à
l'enquêté ce sont les accusations
portées ce mardi 3 août par human rights
watch à l'encontre des autorités
libanaises à la veille du funèbres
premier anniversaire de l'explosion qui
a dévasté le port de beyrouth le 4 août
2020 l'omg recommande non seulement une
mission d'investigation de l'onu mais
aussi des sanctions internationales
envers de hauts responsables libanais
plusieurs autorités libanaises ont été
au minimum criminellement négligente en
vertu de la loi libanaise dans leur
gestion de la cargaison en créant un
risque déraisonnable pour la vie humaine
certains responsables gouvernementaux
ont anticipé et accepté tacitement les
risques de décès posés par la présence
de nitrates d'ammonium dans le port dans
la législation nationale
cela est susceptible de constituer un
crime d'homicide avec intention probable
et ou d'homicide involontaire en vertu
du droit international des droits de
l'homme
mais l'incapacité d'un et à agir pour
prévenir des risques prévisibles pour la
vie viole le droit à la vie comment des
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium se sont
elles retrouvées dans le port de
beyrouth qu'est ce qui a déclenché
l'incendié à l'origine de l'explosion
pourquoi ce nitrate d'ammonium
etait-il stockés dans un entrepôt d la
dre à ces questions aucune réponse n'a
encore été apportée au cours de cette
année d'en quête à la mi juin
cinquante trois ong ont réclamé qu'une
enquête soit menée par l'onu
le 2 août dernier c'est amnesty
international qui a accusé les autorités
libanaises de sabots telle enquête
les autorités libanaises ont promis
qu'une enquête allait être promptement
menée en raison de façon éhontée bloqué
et retardé le cours de la justice à
maintes reprise malgré l'un la sable
campagne pour la justice et la reddition
de comptes mené par des victimes et des
familles de victimes malgré les mises en
garde répétées deux ong celle enquête
n'avance pas le 10 décembre 2020 hassan
diab le premier ministre démissionnaire
ainsi que trois anciens ministres sont
inculpés par le juge fadi sawan en
charge de l'enquêté sur l'explosion de
des ministres accusés réclame la
récusation du juge
l'enquète est suspendu une semaine plus
tard fadi sawan le juge est ensuite
récusé le 18 février dernier par la cour
de cassation qui nomme à sa place tarek
bitar ce dernier a annoncé début juillet
son intention de demander des comptes
hassan diab et a exhorté le parlement a
levé l'immunité de trois députés et
anciens ministres afin je cite
d'intenter des poursuites pour potentiel
intention d'homicide et négligence et
manquement
le parlement réclame plus de preuves
mais tard et guitare rejette cette
demande
depuis c'est le statu quo l' enquête
serait au trois quart achevé selon une
source judiciaire citée par la fp
d'après l'agencé un document interne de
la sûreté de l'état datant de plusieurs
mois avant l'explosion indiqué que des
matières dangereuses étaient stockés
dans un entrepôt et alertait sur les
risques d'un énorme incendie qui
pourrait presque entièrement détruire le
port aujourd'hui hassan diab est
toujours inculpé et 18 personnes sont en
détention dans le cadre de la sphère
roula talent analyste politique était
notre invité les explique pourquoi à la
dirigeants et responsables de
l'explosion sont encore là aujourd'hui
c'est des gens qui sans des employés
chez les partis politiques et en
l'occurrence lâché le hezbollah en ce
qui concerne le port de beyrouth et le
stockage des armes et du nitrate de
l'ammonium qui était qui n'est plus un
secret d'une investigation française et
d'autres investigations
ce sont des armes qui étaient utilisés
pour la guerre en syrie deux ans et
stocker ce genre d'armes presse
nucléaire entre les maisons et causé
tant de man étant de descriptions à sa
seule demande gré elles l'arrestation
immédiate de faisans là ou bien au moins
la décence de quitter leur poste ils
n'ont pas quitté leur poste ils s'en
fichent du juge
ils ne veulent pas comparaître devant
lui et jusqu'à présent jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
ils ont l'appui de certains certains
partis politiques
lucette vu l'ampleur de ce qui s'est
passé la colère des gens la colère des
des parents des victimes des familles
des victimes ces gens là à risque lynché
dans la rue ebrahim raïssi approuvé
comme nouveau président aujourd'hui la
passation de pouvoir s'est faite ce
mardi à téhéran lors d'une cérémonie
officielle présidée par le guide suprême
de l'iran l'ayatollah ali khamenei à san
juan y en a profité pour féliciter son
successeur l'ancien chef d'état quitte
elle ses fonctions au milieu d'une série
de crises liées notamment à l'accord sur
le nucléaire et à la pandémie de
nombreux défis attendent
raïssi qui prendra ses fonctions le 5
août prochain
la mine à mendeala les dossiers
s'accumulent sur la table d'ebrahim
raïssi désormais officiellement
président dès son élection le nouveau
chef d'état s'est dit prêt à poursuivre
le travail de son prédécesseur hassan
rohani nous allons certainement utiliser
les expériences du gouvernement actuel
avec la coopération de monsieur roy ni
et de tous les membres du gouvernement
j'utiliserai certainement les opinions
points de vue expériences et rapport des
ministres et fonctionnaires estimé
pendant cette période d'un mois et demi
l'homme âgé de 60 ans doit traiter
plusieurs dossiers brûlants
parmi eux l'épineuse question du
nucléaire
des pourparlers avec certaines grandes
puissances avaient repris dès l'entrée
de joe biden à la maison blanche
mais enfin la décision de son
prédécesseur donald trump d'abandonner
l'accord de vienne
mais washington et téhéran peine à
rétablir un lien de confiance
le fait est que c'est l'iran qui est des
décisions à prendre des décisions
fondamentales à prendre pour savoir s'il
veut lui aussi revenir au respect de
l'accord et aucun niveau de diversion ne
peut changer ce fait fondamental
la balle reste dans le camp de l'iran et
nous verrons s'ils sont prêts à prendre
les décisions nécessaires pour revenir
au respect de l'accord
nous sommes attachés à la diplomatie
mais ce processus ne peut pas se
poursuivre indéfiniment à scana l'accord
actuellement suspendu devrait être
relancé dès la prise de fonction
d'ebrahim raïssi mais les négociations
pourraient toutefois être ralenti par le
dernier incident opposant la république
islamique d'iran à l'état hébreu israël
accuse téhéran d'être à l'origine de
l'attaqué meurtrière d'un navire géré
par un milliardaire israélien dans la
merde oman un contexte qui complique le
rétablissement des relations avec l'iran
mercredi dernier ali khamenei le guide
suprême d'iran mettait en garde les
générations futures devraient se servir
de l'expérience du gouvernement rouani
il est apparu clairement en cours du
mandat de ce gouvernement que faire
confiance à l'occident ne fonctionne pas
la crise économique et sociale dans le
pays
est amplifié par la pandémie du
coronavirus elle vient s'ajouter à la
liste des dossiers auxquels le nouveau
président iranien devra faire face en
juillet des manifestations parties de
pénurie d'eau dans la région pétrolifère
du khouzistan on se courait tout le pays
en bosnie herzégovine christian schmidt
a pris ses fonctions de haut
représentant international
hier une nouvelle qui est loin de ravir
les serbes de bosnie explication alexis
kong mario caudal à peine arrivé et déjà
loin de faire l'unanimité
l'ancien ministre allemand de
l'agriculture christian schmidt est
depuis hier haut représentant
international en bosnie herzégovine sa
mission veiller au bon respect des
accords de paix de dayton des accords
qui ont mis fin en 1995 à une guerre
civile meurtrière un conflit marqués
notamment par le massacre de srebrenica
au cours duquel les forces serbes ont
tué environ 8000 bosniaques musulmans à
l'époque
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
qualifient le conflit de nettoyage
ethnique et de génocide
ce que les serbes de bosnie toujours
aujourd'hui en dépit de la condamnation
de certains responsables militaires et
politiques de l'époque par la justice
internationale
car près de trente ans après les
tensions intercommunautaires dans ce
pays des balkans subsistent encore
d'autant plus qu'avant de quitter ses
fonctions de haut représentant le
prédécesseur de christian schmidt le
diplomate autrichien valentin inzko a vu
sa décision d'interdire la négation des
faits de génocide provoqué une levée de
boucliers du côté serbe
pas de quoi décourager christian schmidt
qui veut remettre la bosnie herzégovine
à l'agenda politique de la communauté
internationale notamment à travers son
adhésion à l'otan et sa candidature à
l'entrée dans l'union européenne
crowther décevant je contribuerai à ce
travail et je suis très optimiste quant
à la capacité de la communauté
internationale des européens des
américains et de tous les autres pays du
monde
à travailler ensemble pour y parvenir
mais si l'ancien ministre allemand est
soutenu par la plupart des pays
occidentaux la russie a elle déjà fait
part de sa désapprobation de sa
nomination
les serbes de bosnie affichent quant à
eux leur détermination à s'opposer à la
politique annoncée par le nouveau haut
représentant international
nous n'allons pas coopérer avec le haut
représentant international et nous
l'appliquerons pas ses décisions
une défiance que christian schmidt n'a
pas encore commenté
il doit rencontrer aujourd'hui les
membres bosniaque croate et serbe de la
présidence collégiale
on passe au reste de l'actualité en bref
et en images la grèce frappée par une
énorme vague de chaleur depuis plusieurs
jours les températures varient entre 40
et 45 degrés à thème tous les sites
archéologiques sont fermées aux heures
les plus chaudes de 12h à 17h elle des
températures caniculaires qui
entretiennent fort risque d' incendies
partout dans le pays
sur l'île de rhodes et dans le
nord-ouest du péloponnèse et les
pompiers luttent pour maîtriser
d'importants feux de forêt en israël le
gouvernement de dar talib et net
approuvé hier le budget de l'état une
première depuis trois ans est depuis à
2018 aucun budget n'avait été à de près
sur fond de l'impasse politique mais
tout n'est pas joué
la nouvelle loi budgétaire sera présenté
au parlement dans les prochaines
semaines s'il n'est pas accepter la
knesset sera automatiquement dissoute et
les israéliens devront retourner aux
urnes 90 jours
en côte d'ivoire laurent gbagbo réitère
sa volonté est de faire libérer une
centaine de prisonniers qu'ils
considèrent comme politique
une demande déjà adressé la semaine
dernière au chef de l'état alassane
ouattara
parmi cette liste de 110 détenus
figurent à des personnes arrêtées lors
de la crise post électorale de 2010 mais
aussi lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle 2020 c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi prochain point sur l'actualité
dans un pub de 30 minutes tout de suite
un nouveau magazine d'information
restait bien avec tous sur rtl
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme ça